One of the things that we've really been trying
to figure out is what is the real rate of
Corona virus infection, because the official
numbers only tell us the number of people
that have actually had a test and tested positive
for the disease.
But of course, there's a whole bunch of people
who have or have had Corona virus without
being tested, many of whom have already recovered.
And one of the ways you can test for the real
rate is to do an antibody test, the antibodies
produced by the body in the process of or
after finishing the process of fighting the
virus.
But there have been antibody tests that have
not been accurate.
So that has not been particularly useful.
There have also been studies that have tested
sewage and depending on which test you look
at.
We've heard that the real infection rate could
be as small as two times the official rate
or as large as 250 times the official rate.
Now, I've said before only two times the official
rate sounds low to me, 250 times the official
rate sounds too high to me.
If it were 250 times the official rate, we'd
be talking about roughly 200 million Americans
with Corona virus.
And that does not seem to pass the sniff test,
although if it were true, we would potentially
be close to herd immunity.
But it doesn't pass the sniff test.
So in looking at different data, my thought
has been the real number of infections is
somewhere between four and 30 times the official
number, which is still a very big range.
We have a new study from Los Angeles County
that is looking at exactly this question.
What is the real rate of infection?
They went and they gave antibody tests to
a random sample of eight hundred and sixty
three adults.
And they found that somewhere between two
hundred and twenty thousand four hundred and
forty thousand people in Los Angeles County
have already been infected.
Now, when you compare those numbers to the
official case, number of just under 14000
at the time that the study was done, this
study implies that the real infection number
is somewhere between 15 and 30 times the official
case number.
Now, if we apply that to the entire United
States, it would suggest between 12 and 24
million people have or have had Corona virus
so far or really have had, because you don't
have antibodies when you're actively infected.
Now, as always, there's a bunch of caveats
here.
One is no one's study is likely to be the
one.
Infection rates are realistically different
and different different parts of the country.
And importantly, even if this is correct,
we would be nowhere near herd immunity at
this point in time.
The good news, if the real rate of infection
is 15 to 30 times the official rate is it
implies a far lower fatality rate than we
think because a much smaller portion of people
are dying.
If you have a thousand deaths out of ten thousand
infections, that's much more serious than
if you have a thousand deaths out of 100000
infections.
Now, the bad news of the real rate being 15
to 30 times the official rate is that it means
the virus spreads way more easily than we
thought.
And we are nowhere near having a testing system
that can actually identify a large portion
of the cases.
If you can identify cases, you can't contact
trace, you can't tell people who might have
been exposed that they need to quarantine.
But as always, any one study can be way off.
We've learned that some antibody tests are
just very an accurate fundamentally.
Technically speaking, I believe some of those
tests may have been used in this study.
The other thing to keep in mind is the more
you test, the closer you are to the real infection
rate.
So I want to be really clear about this.
We can't just take the nationwide number and
multiply it by 15 to 30 based on the L.A.
County results.
Why not?
I'll give you an example.
New York is testing way more than California.
New York has tested 33000 people for every
million in the population, whereas California
has only tested 7000 people for every million
in the population.
Since California has not been testing as much
as New York.
We would imagine that the real infection rate
in California is many times higher than the
real infection rate in New York because New
York has tested more people.
That's what we know right now.
Someday we'll have a good antibody test.
We can rely on.
We'll figure out what the real penetrance
of the disease has been across the country.
We're not there yet.
And the reality that we have right now is
we are certainly undercounting cases.
We
just don't.
Know exactly by how much